about this let's get started and talk
about this first story because it's
friday the story is stupid and funny at
the same time
we had this tweet from alexandria
ocasio-cortez who said
tired of having to collectively stress
about what explosion of hate crimes is
happening because some billionaire with
an ego problem unilaterally controls a
massive communication platform and skews
it because tucker carlson or peter thiel
took him to dinner and made him feel
special to which elon musk responded
stop hitting on me i'm really shy and a
blushing emoji
michael malus you can see under he says
he ratioed her in minutes and then the
response to him was so you don't know
how the ratio works got it and she got
ratio
so here's the funny thing uh jack
posobik i guess captured what aoc said i
i guess some people are saying she
deleted it aoc said i was talking about
zuckerberg but okay i think she deleted
it because she realized she only made it
worse yeah to be fair she was talking
about zuckerberg you think so she says
controls a platform and was taken out to
dinner by tucker carlson or peter thiel
zuckerberg was famously taken out to
dinner for some meeting by conservatives
and he currently controls a platform i
just think it's hilarious that elon musk
threw back in her face which she does
because ocasio-cortez famously says stop
hitting on me you're trying to date me i
think it's funny when people criticize
aoc her stands go she's not gonna date
you bro it's like is that your only is
that is that your bit is that your bit
cause okay all right well elon musk just
threw the pie back in her face yeah also
is mark zuckerberg considered right wing
now
ol mark convincing people to commit hate
crimes what is this well anybody to the
right of karl marx is considered that's
true oh no no karl marx himself is far
right no he was racist oh true true and
a womanizer
you have to remember real racism hasn't
been tried yet all right if he did it
the way marx wanted it would work oh yes
it's funny how it's you know russia is
coming out saying that they want to
denazify europe or something like that
and then you think about the
similarities between the woke cult
critical race i did terrorism all this
stuff and it's like
yeah i understand the similarities i
don't think they're the same ones more
like
i guess ultra traditionalist and ones
ultra progressive one wanted to destroy
the culture one wanted to restore it but
they were both authoritarians who wanted
government based on race
and so here we go i don't i don't see a
very large difference between these two
groups
speaking of karl marx yeah no karl marx
he was the absolute worst and part of
why he's so interesting is because when
you look at his personal life you see
how unbelievably poorly conducted it was
and it's just the case that when people
don't want to live properly they'll try
to create philosophies that justify
being a bad person basically and that's
what marxism is and it's just sad to see
how many people have bought into it and
how much destruction it's caused there
was there was a paul johnson wrote a
book called intellectual yes where he
went into the the like the personal
lives of like zsa crouseau and karl marx
and pretty much all these intellectuals
they weren't i mean predominantly
left-wing but he wanted to say like okay
how well have these people actually
lived out their own philosophy and it
was incredible when you read about jazz
rousseau and the kids that he fathered
and immediately threw into some of the
worst orphanages in paris where they
basically died of like starvation and
neglect and then karl marx who always
said within communism right the the last
phase of capitalism is people will
actually pay their employers to work
and that's crazy because that doesn't
really happen except in karl marx's
personal life where he actually had a
servant that he didn't really pay and
repeatedly you know
i wouldn't say raped but repeatedly had
a just had an affair with right of you
know
so it was great he he actually he
actually had the manifestation of the
last phase of what he said capitalism
would bring about yeah well and this is
why you have to be extremely suspicious
of people who harp on and on about how
they love humanity in this abstract
sense yes because very often times
they're trying to overcompensate for the
fact that they treat everyone in their
personal life like absolute garbage
which is fundamentally the only way you
really can love humanity is by treating
those around you well instead of
throwing vague platitudes out there
about how much you want world peace and
poverty etc somebody posted a
photo of auntie for marching and they
were like why wouldn't anyone want to be
anti-fun i'm like are we doing this
again they're saying the same thing
again and but i just what i noticed
about the photo was that the antifa guys
were really scrawny
like gaunt like thin what's wrong with
that tim
these people haven't lifted a heavy
object in their lives no not all of them
so i'm sure some have there are probably
some you know some guys
i'm not saying literally everyone but
you look at anti-but they tend to be
they tend to be the where they call the
laptop class they're not working class
they get money from sitting around
complaining on the internet either for
writing writing for buzzfeed or
something you're really sub tweeting me
here man and i'm just like well look
it's it's one thing if you are part of
the laptop class and you advocate for
the workers and you recognize the value
of hard work and you're not saying give
me free stuff while i smash your windows
yeah it's another thing when you don't
do any work and then say i'm the workers
of the world that's me
you should unite with me i'm like dude
you don't do work like marching around
and complaining about stuff you know
sometimes there's an element of work in
there you know we got to fight for our
rights i get that but you ain't lifting
any rocks or building any walls you're
not growing any crops it's fascinating
how little these people actually know
about their whole world well we're not
building walls tim because we believe in
bridges i'm sorry that you don't
that's right now aoc was a bartender and
everybody makes fun of her for that that
was the most productive thing for
humanity she ever did was attending bar
and you know and and look i'm not saying
that pejoratively i'm saying
i have bartenders that i know they're
really good friends and they are
providing a product or service through
voluntary cooperation within the
marketplace god bless you
bartenders do actual work that's the one
thing you shouldn't smear her for being
a politician is really embarrassing
being a bartender isn't it oh i know
exactly what i'm actually i feel
horrible about it
i have voluntarily given bartenders my
money yes in the past right i just think
it's funny that
people found the one thing she was good
at to complain about it's like so she
actually had a job she was doing it she
was she was working class she was
providing um relaxation and
entertainment to tired individuals i
think bars are fantastic why make fun of
her for that yeah make fun of her for
being having an economics degree and not
knowing what capitalism is
or you know for tweeting things she
knows what capitalism it's mean that's
what capitalism is she tweeted
capitalism is when you're a billionaire
actually you can't be a capitalist if
you're not a billionaire
yeah she posted on instagram she was
like people aren't capitalists because
they don't have billions of dollars and
it's like what that's how that works
that is how that's like so did you
google it
i i look you know to be fair i can't
blame her
these like these colleges are just
garbage oh i
one of the biggest eye-opening events
for me was i i kind of went to college
late in life i was out of the military
already i was like 30 i was in an
english class this is what surprised me
i was in an english class at northern
virginia community college and then all
of a sudden the professor pulls out the
communist manifesto for us to read
because nothing screams english
literature like a book written by a
german communist but
um
he comes back the week later and asked
the class like what do you think of
capitalism the student raises his hand
and goes well i think capitalism is
what's destroying this country
and i just had to stop i'm like look
just real quick can you can you tell me
what you think capitalism is
and he proceeds to go out well
capitalism is this you know this rigid
class-based structure with the people
that i said no no i didn't ask what karl
marx's caricature of capitalism is can
you actually give me the definition
the professor looks over and goes well
can you
i said yeah it's a form of economics
where people have exchanged goods and
services voluntarily and and property
rights are
you know respected
okay we can use that oh well thank god
we can use the definition of capitalism
when we're discussing capitalism but
you're right that was the point like
everyone in that classroom had a version
of capitalism taught to them that born
no resemblance to what capitalism
actually is as an economics i think
exactly the sorry the simple definition
is
it's an economic system built upon
private exchange of goods and labor yes
that's it the i think she might be
complaining about that the problem is
actually greed i mean maybe maybe
capitalism unh unfettered creates
oligarchies of private corporations
which is the problem so you know
unfettered gov of any kind of economic
system is dangerous you always need some
sort of regulation otherwise people
seize control will attempt to seize
power but i think it's greed that she's
really talking about but i mean if you
agreed in a communist system it's it
turns out way worse than greed in a
capitalist system from my experience
again referencing thomas soul he used to
always bring this up he's like whenever
we try to explain greed is the problem
for something soul likes to come back
and look at this like okay great go sit
on your couch right now and think really
greedy thoughts and see what happens
nothing right there's there's always an
action that we have to actually look at
and observe to determine how you know
what because
alexander recorded cortez elizabeth
warren bernie sanders some of the
greediest people on the planet if you
actually look at the definition of greed
which is i want things without actually
having to work for those things i want
to be able to take those things from an
authoritarian standpoint that's far more
greedy than hey i want some stuff so i'm
going to go ahead and produce a bunch of
goods and services that people will
voluntarily exchange with me on right
yeah you know and i would agree ian that
any system when it becomes unfettered is
going to be problematic and
i think the problem is they fell to see
that these flaws of human nature are
going to exist within any system so what
and like you said when you have a greedy
communist dictator i think that's a lot
more dangerous than a private individual
who happens to be greedy and often like
you said what they will refer to as
greed isn't always necessarily greedy
sometimes it is like yeah a lot of giant
corporations are extremely greedy a lot
of actors within the market are greedy
but that's a question of the level of
virtue our society has cultivated not
necessarily just the economic system
right because if everyone's greedy then
no one is greedy relatively because it's
relative greed is relative to the system
you've set up yet to exist within well
even i don't know if i entirely agree
but even if everyone is greedy i don't
think i don't think any system's gonna
work if everyone operating within that
system is vicious well like you said
nick so greed is more the intention but
you're saying it's the outcome that
produces the problem is that stealing
then is she talking about stealing so
here's what i go back to right the
question is is
again people are flawed i think we can
all agree on that people are flawed the
question is is does the economic system
you have adopted what does it encourage
or what does it incentivize within a
capitalist system where essentially i
have to protect your property rights and
we can only engage in exchange if it's
voluntarily and theoretically to mutual
benefit well then now i have a positive
incentive structure so even if i am
really greedy if the way that i actually
get the more money or the more stuff
that i want if the best way for me to do
that is providing as many people as
possible
goods and services that they want then
even if i have a negative intention i
have an economic system that fuels that
intention in a positive outworking
if on the other hand i'm gaining it by
taking your stuff through force and
violence well i mean i'm sorry i don't
think that produces better results so
there's another uh example of this in a
certain sense scott pressler he's uh
well known for registering people to
vote and he's also really well known for
cleaning up cities he went to baltimore
he went to a bunch of cities and he's
cleaned up garbage and it was funny uh
he got a bunch of trump supporters to go
out and clean up garbage and the
communities were like thank you so much
for cleaning up and making our
neighborhood nice and it's no problem we
want to show people we're here to do the
work to make the you know make our
everyone's lives better and then the
media smeared him they were like he's
just doing this to get trump votes and
i'm like
oh no oh he sure tricked us he went out
and cleaned up a bunch of garbage to
convince us that he was a good person i
mean he did so you know in looking at
aoc's complaints about capitalism it's
like
shouldn't the attitude when a big
business is like we're going to make a
billion dollars by curing diseases you'd
be like oh okay
now
i think the real criticism is when these
companies don't cure the diseases and
when these companies start to when they
say well we don't want to cure it
because these people are customers and
we want to keep making money off it and
the issue is aoc sees that and says that
is all of capitalism and it's like no
that is a corruption of the system that
we need to deal with yeah these offshore
bank accounts is another one because you
can't really call it stealing if they
set up a loophole for themself legally
and then take the money and put it
somewhere where it's not supposed to be
but it is stealing it's just they just
wrote it on paper that i'm this is no
longer considered stealing and then they
do it
so
you know well
people so
there was a tweet from uh
jen perlman who had on the show she's
progressive
and she said
you know we got to end these tax
loopholes
billionaires don't pay their fair share
i said what what do you think is fair is
55 fair share for billionaires and she
said i think if we close the loopholes
it would be
20 to like 25 to 35 which is actually
lowering yeah the tax liability for the
wealthy but i think a lot of these
people on the left are actually
concerned about the corruption and
manipulation of the tax system as
opposed to how much they're actually
paying and i completely agree so like
maybe if we can have that argument be
like yes figure out a way to make sure
those who are supposed to pay taxes do
pay them
and we can lower the taxes
sounds good to me right people shouldn't
be committing crimes and people should
have less taxes no no absolutely i mean
yeah there's a lot of manipulation
within the tax code and like again i
said on the finance committee we write
the tax code for the commonwealth of
virginia and there's a lot of debates in
there about tax credits or subsidization
or or things of that nature
and i think there's a very good argument
to be made that no it's like there's the
tax code should be relatively simple to
understand
and it shouldn't be something where
you're setting up a system where the
people the best lobbyists get the
cutouts
the problem that i have with the whole
fair share argument is because they
never come back and say oh this is what
a fair share is because they don't want
to because they want the argument of the
rich aren't paying their fair share
because now they haven't defined what
that is and they're also ignoring the
fact that the the you know the
wealthiest whatever half of the country
the wealthiest 10 percent of the country
pay the vast vast vast majority of taxes
especially at the federal level there's
no question with all the loopholes with
everything they pay the vast majority of
it and they pay a higher percentage than
what they actually control within the
economy that's just a fact i just got to
tell people
taxes are crazy they're insane yes
seriously
insane you know we anybody who runs a
business knows exactly how insane taxes
are yeah and a lot of these leftists are
people who don't run businesses no as
soon as you start your own business look
at david hogg yeah he tweets like why is
it so hard to start an llc what's going
on with these regulations like
yeah yeah hey dave go find a mirror look
in it real hard
but no no i look he's a young guy and he
didn't know and he got a cold splash of
water in the face i'm not here to rag on
him i'm here to say
stand alongside me brother and let's
figure out how to make this easier for
americans to
create businesses you know the
the way i see it is
if somebody says
you know if aoc came to me and said i
think you know i just got my paycheck
and these taxes are insane i'd be like
let's work together on a solution i'm
glad you're finally seeing the problem
we're seeing what can we do to fix it if
somebody is an activist and they're
going off the rails and then something
happens to them where they start to
realize i'm not going to rag on them i'm
going to be like come over and have
let's let's do this let's fix this
problem yeah well i think fundamentally
the problem is envy so for all the talk
that the left does
about how greed is destroying our
economy in some respects i would argue
that it is i think that an unvirtuous
population is a very dangerous thing and
greed is not the only vice that's
commonplace in our culture now i would
say that generally
the market economy
gives you more of what the people were
already interested in in the first place
so it's going to veer off into a
negative direction if you don't have a
population that has positive values uh
however 100 and but but on top of that
so
i don't think capitalism is perfect i
don't think a market's perfect there are
certain regulations i certainly believe
in
but at the same time it seems to me as
if other systems like socialism
are literally built a top vice so while
capitalism can allow for greed to
flourish socialism requires envy the the
issue is
that these people know
communism works and it works really
really well
once you've killed everyone who
disagrees with communism
so you just got to remove that surplus
population and we're going to go and
what happens is you end up with a very
very very tiny tiny population so you
have to kill a lot of people which is
why they've always done it yeah so if
you have
because because humans are not
homogeneous because humans are are
diverse with different ideas
you'll have this big population and some
are going to descend so what do these
these communists always do kill them all
and hopefully you keep purging the
descent and you'll keep your rigid
fear-based economy functioning well this
goes back to your this goes back to
shameless point as well i've asked this
question before i'm like all right
you're a socialist so you you again
capitalism is the private ownership the
means of production distribution through
voluntary exchange socialism is the you
know collective ownership of the means
of production here's my question you
want to be a socialist in a capitalist
country in the united states of america
you can be you can go get some of your
friends right now you can go get
property you can go share it
collectively you can open up a commune
and not only will i as a raging
capitalist not bother you
i will fight to lower your taxes
the only thing i ask in return is you
can't force me to go with you and you
can't force me to subsidize it that's it
and that's not good enough no so they're
free to live the way they want in this
country they want to require me to do it
right this is what i was finding funny
because uh ron paul said something like
this country allows socialism they they
need to just go make their commune and
they'd have it but they don't do it and
it's because they don't actually want
communism they don't actually want
socialism they want your stuff
that's why they say we want to seize the
means of production it's like dude
somebody works really really hard and
builds a farm what happens the
communists seize the farm because the
means of production and that everybody
starves they don't want to do the work
they just want what you got and they
will burn the system down to get it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time